I think in the UK, people are just
sort of reckoning now with
the existence of anti-Semitism
and I think that,
that sort of self-interrogation
is very difficult for people.
I think it's an identity crisis in
the UK - people understanding
that anti-Semitism
does in fact exist.
I have experienced anti-Semitism
from people who are on the far left
and the far right, and people who are
black and white, men and women.
Anti-Semitism is not restricted
to one party or gender or race.
Anti-Semitism is for everybody.
This is a news clip
from the late-1950s.
A swastika got painted
on a synagogue in Leeds.
Finally, are you worried?
No, not in the least, there's
nothing to be worried about -
one ignores these things.
I think that’s so British,
to just be Iike,
"Yes, there's nothing to worry about,
one ignores these things."
But I also think that's
sort of the reason that...
The vast majority of people
are not actively anti-Semitic.
And when anti-Semitic stuff
like that did happen,
and for many years when it has
happened, it's sort of like,
"Oh well, we'll wash it off the wall
and get on with business as usual."
And now that it's back in the
forefront, I think it's shocking for
people precisely because
it is the kind of thing that
you would move past.
It's so interesting to watch this,
because this feels like
1930's rhetoric.
This Orban speech sums up
so much of anti-Semitic rhetoric,
because he says,
"Not open, but hiding.
Not straightforward, but crafty."
And then he goes,
"Not national, but international."
It's that tie between
nationalism and anti-Semitism
that Jews are somehow not from here -
they don't belong here.
They're part of this global cabal,
that's here to
take stuff away from us.
And always the crafty thing.
There's no way to describe Jews
that doesn't sound ludicrous
when they go into sort of
that stereotype they're like,
"They're crafty" or "They're sneaky"
"They're wily."
I think Jews get bludgeoned
with Israel sometimes.
I think Israel is like a very weird
lead pipe for a lot of people
they're just like,
"Well, you're Jewish,
so explain this Israeli policy."
And you're like, "Well, I don't know
if I 100% agree with that policy,
because, you know...
And they're like, "Well, then do
you think Israel shouldn't exist?"
And you're like, "Well no.
That's not what I said either."
Israel is a very complicated issue,
and it is the only sort of
Jewish homeland on earth
so for that reason, Jews do have
a special affiliation with it.
And it is a place, by the way,
where I love my time in Israel,
because it is one of the only
places where I do not feel
othered for being Jewish.
I've taken issue with many of its
policies in the same way that
I take issue with many of the UK's
policies and many American policies.
But I do think...
...or it's used to
justify anti-Semitism.
My favorite quote about anti-Semitism
is this Jean-Paul Sartre quote,
which is that...
...and I think about that
all the time.
I do think that a good way
to reduce anti-Semitism
is for people to understand
that Jew is a label
or Jew as a type is a label
that is entirely constructed.
It doesn't mean that you are a
type of person or a certain way.
There is a strong heritage which you
may opt into if you so choose.
I think it's crucial for people to
understand that Jews are complicated
in the same way that
everybody else is.
There are rich Jews and poor Jews,
and Jews who are educated,
and Jews who are not.
And if you think all Jews are sort
of powerful and educated and rich,
I have a bunch of cousins
that you should meet,
because it's not the case.